nous allons évoquer ici les sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation en france une quinzaine
de zones ont été sélectionnés dans les
années 90 par des militants dieu
la première erreur de notes
administration a été de croire que les
terroristes étaient des loups solitaires
alors qu'ils étaient là résultant de 15
ans de travail de fond fait par les
allemands eon clair ils ont prêché la
guerre sainte et le problème c'est qu'on
les a trop longtemps les échos il ya eu
un espèce de déni de réalité et il a
fallu le drame du bataclan pour qu'il y
ait enfin une reconnaissance générale de
la situation dans notre pays
la ministre de la justice mme belloubet
annonce la sortie en 2020 de 43 du à 10
140 avant fin 2022 sur les 531 incarcéré
aujourd'hui
qui peut croire que la majeure partie
des individus mus par la haine de la
france est désormais libre ne sont pas
un défi pour la sécurité nationale
[Musique]